non-minimalists
i have a small business and work out of
my home and paper is my enemy
i unsubscribe from everything try to get
off contact list and have turned
everything i can into e statements
however i still have the past seven
years of tax returns documents receipts
and other types of papers that i don't
know what to do with
i tried to go paperless last year for my
business but the app
i was using would mysteriously delete
images and spending and mileage that i
had spent time
inputting so i cancelled it because it
made me nervous
my question is how can i go paperless
for both my life and business
i get so worried that my computer will
crash or i'll have a fire or flood
but i also am not great with technology
and don't fully understand backing
things up or using the cloud and things
like that
so ryan when i hear emily here i i
certainly identify with this although
i see some problems with her problem i
do
um what do you see well the first thing
i see is she said she's not adept
with using some of these things and
you know having enough uh living a
minimalist lifestyle it's there's
it's not easy yeah it's it's it's
difficult
and there are some things that you're
gonna uh
in her case there are some things you're
to have to maybe go out of your way and
learn how
to do right so um so that's that's my
way of saying
to emily here is don't be scared of the
technology
right embrace it yeah um you and i
didn't know how to do it until we knew
how to do it
exactly like go out of your way to
a give yourself permission to kind of uh
mess up a little bit and have a little
bit of a learning curve i mean not to
the extent of like
obviously we don't want her records
getting deleted but
uh but just don't be nervous going into
technology i don't know how else to say
it that's that's the first the problem
that i see is that she sounds a little
trepidatious to get into the different
apps and it's understandable because
it's overwhelming
and so i want to i want to break down
the problem make it a little bit less
overwhelming and in fact once we
identify what enough is you won't be
overwhelmed at all right now you're
overwhelmed because
you have more than enough information
now ryan and i are going to share some
practical tips with you we have some
articles i'll put a link to both of them
in the show notes
we'll get to those in a moment because
there are some practical
things you can do however it's quixotic
to think that i can just do
i can add some apps and some technology
and
by adding more that's how i'll get down
to enough
yeah and that's why i thought this was
such a good question for this episode
because
we're not doing a full paper clutter
episode but it's worth at least
discussing now yeah
let's be clear ryan you and i aren't
paperless
we don't have a paper in fact here's
here's the ultimate irony here's this
new york times article we're going to
read from in a moment
or at least we'll put a link to in the
show it's called gear for a paperless
off home office gear for a paperless
home office i've printed this out
on paper that's great now i do that for
the podcast for a reason let me
i don't just want to print things
willy-nilly but ryan and i have found
that
having screens between us actually
degrades the conversation yeah
and we're trying to avoid that and so if
i have to print out some paper which by
the way
is a renewable resource i've talked to
environmentalists
we've interviewed quite a few and
they're like well you know honestly if
you're if you're
getting if you're printing from using
your regrowth
forests if you actually care about trees
you use paper
right which seems counterintuitive to me
i'm not completely on board with that
yet
right i don't just like randomly use a
bunch of paper but for this podcast it
makes more sense than having
screens that create a barrier for us
in fact i often think that our screens
are are creating
all these new barriers there's a lot of
talk about building a wall
we've built walls and they're digital
walls
in between all of us when you go out you
see it in memes all the time now where
it's like
people are all family around the dinner
table and they're all just like staring
into this
this really enticing glowing box
i read a meme and said something like uh
i'll be watching uh netflix on the
internet um
uh and then i get bored so i have to see
what's going on on the little internet
yeah that's that's such a good point
it's like we don't watch tv anymore we
watch the internet
on the big internet or the small
internet right now we have medium
internet
the ronnie chang joke which is also in
love people use things in the technology
chapter
he says it seems like you know he's an
immigrant and he said
it seems like every night in america is
a contest to see how many screens i can
get between my face and the wall
yeah and he goes through the whole bit
and it's like the tv
and then i've got like my laptop and my
ipad and my iphone and then boom apple
watch
right oh my gosh yeah we have all these
screens in between us so
what i'm really saying here is if you
have a
problem that is not solvable
uh by technology i'm sorry that you
think is solvable by technology it may
be solvable when you better understand
the problem
it may be solvable without technology as
well so let's help emily understand
let's do that so first off uh becoming
completely paperless
is sort is fine but if we're renouncing
paper i'm never ever going to use paper
again
what does that do when you renounce
something it forever attaches you to it
right and so by renouncing paper what
emily has done inadvertently
and that's this is why it's so
overwhelming to her at first she's now
attached herself to
not just paper but the idea that i must
be paperless
and therefore any bit of paper is an
indiscretion
and i have failed if i bring one post-it
note into my home office
yes so emily just consider yourself
paperless-ish yeah paper full
i mean you are paper full right now but
here's the thing what's the big problem
if
you've if you've gone out of your way to
be relatively paperless
or reduce the amount of paper that you
have maybe was a better way to put it
a paper reduction yeah if you have seven
years of tax records because your
accountant says
you need seven years of tax records okay
what's the problem with that if you have
the essential tax records i don't see a
problem with that
i have one file cabinet at home me too
that has some tax information
has some receipts in there and then i'll
go through there every 90 days and i
call
the superfluous information out of there
and anything i don't need gets shredded
and then boom i'm i'm done i don't have
to spend a ton of time on it
and i don't have to worry about it
because i know quarterly i just go
through there
extract the things and then also we have
an accountant who actually handles our
business paperwork yeah and so maybe
that's an option i don't know if you
have an accountant but they may be able
to store the things for you so
our accountant actually stores our tax
information for us
which is really helpful and they store
it in the cloud it's all backed up and
it's secure
and you have to have someone and a
system that you trust
but it's okay to outsource some of that
trust as well yeah
the first thing that comes to mind for
me is like like a quickbooks type thing
where
it handles everything like you can put
taxes in there you can put receipts in
there
um and again emily this is gonna take
especially if you have
seven years worth of paper it's gonna
take some time to go paperless
right or uh to go paperless ish
to reduce your amount of paper but uh
yeah like so with our accountant um
yes like they handle everything but you
don't have to have an accountant
to handle everything you can have an
application that handles we didn't have
an account until a couple years ago
exactly and my feeling too she was
talking about things randomly getting
deleted
i mean there's i don't know what she was
using but there's probably
an easier solution than just giving up
well let's go into some of the solutions
here so before we have a couple articles
here in fact i'm going to put a link to
this one in the show notes
gear for a paperless home office this
has some different scanners and
different software etc
i'm not going to spend time reading
through the the entire article
but i will say that there are different
scanners and things out there that once
you
have understood the complexity of the
problem i'll say one other thing though
before ryan gets into his pc mag article
that he has here
and we'll put a link to that one in the
show notes as well but let me just say
this
that if paper is your enemy then
you might be fighting the wrong battle
right right so i wouldn't treat paper as
the enemy
and i i know you're saying that tongue
in cheek emily but
whenever i think of an enemy then all of
a sudden
i feel as though now i have something
that is insurmountable an enemy it means
i have to fight them i have to battle
them
well paper is just something i need to
scan i don't need to battle it right
and or shred it the truth is most of the
things that i'm holding on to
can probably be shredded without even
scanning it in the first that's what i
realized when i first embraced
minimalism and i was going through those
scanning parties
i was like i was holding on to so much
stuff just in case yeah
but then i just shredded it because i
never i knew i was never going to
actually
need it now you've got an article here
from pc mag what's it called
it is called five apps you need
to go paperless now what i like about
this ryan is it's not specific apps but
it's like a category of apps right
yes yeah what's the first so the first
one is a to-do list
app so there are so many different
versions of this um
i use honestly i use my my notepad i use
apple notes yeah to do to do a to-do
list but there are apps out there that
will help you
color code and organize them a little
different i mean
you've got to decide what you're most
comfortable with evernote is one that i
a lot of people are familiar with sean
would you use something
that's google related right
it's called um google keep yeah that's
it
and any dot do but there's there's some
other there are some other uh
apps in this article as well what's the
the second category second category is
a scanning app i also use apple notes
for that now oh i didn't know you could
do that yeah so apple notes a few
updates ago they added the scanning
capability so you can
scan things with your iphone and there's
a google equivalent if you have an
android smartphone
if you just have a flip phone like uh
the gal that i met over at the
oh oh someone just walked into our
studio here i think i just met a gal
over
at the grocery store the other day and
she's like hey minimalist like i
i um delilah was her name uh she works
at the grocery store she's like i've
been using a flip phone for three months
now
and she was showing them like that's
amazing so then you don't have the
scanning capability so
you and i also have like a photo scanner
document scanner that we've used in the
past before
it was you were able to do it with your
phone yeah that's another option
as well yeah super simple to use
honestly like i use i didn't know i
could do that in notes
i'll start using that now but i just i
use my camera like if i need something
to take a picture of it and then you can
easily convert it to like a pdf or
something yeah that's what notes does
for you using your camera so yeah that's
great what's the next category an
e-signature tool this is pretty
valuable um i use docusign yeah i was
gonna say like i
think i'm just thinking about all the
things that we've had to sign over the
years
and it seems like docusign is like
pretty much the easiest
technology to use yeah there are a few
or fewer places that are requiring
what's called a wet signature it's still
a thing which is
it's so odd it is yeah but if you don't
require a wet signature then
having the the dock you sign or the
equivalent there's no sponsorship here
you do whatever you want
yeah but that's that's just who we use
for sure and then there's a file syncing
service that's category number four
okay so files thinking like dropbox is
what we use for example
uh google has uh their their version of
this as well
box is another company that does the the
so basically
let me explain if my computer were to
crash or my home were to burn down
my entire apartment building burned down
everything
that's on my hard drive would be
destroyed but it's also backed up onto
dropbox and it automatically
syncs dropbox is relatively simple for
me and we pay an annual fee in order to
make
that you know work because you're you're
it's you're paying for storage space
basically
100 i know emily said she wasn't
comfortable with the cloud but again
this is one of those things emily if
if you're not willing to embrace the
technology then
you are going to be stuck with a bunch
of paper right and so and that's okay
that's a cost of admission right of
course
and so there are a couple options here
ryan you can have
in fact i have redundancy and so it's
much safer than if i were just have a
bunch of paperwork in my
attic which i don't have an attic but it
was in my closet and the place burned
down
paperwork's gone and there's nothing i
can do about it there's no way i can
it's not backed up anywhere now if i
have it on my hard drive and then
the paperwork's shredded and then my
hard drive is destroyed then all the
same thing as if my house caught on fire
now if it's on the hard drive and it's
in the cloud now i have some redundancy
yeah so even if something were to happen
to my computer or if something were to
happen in the cloud
i have backup options here 100 and
what's the fifth category right fifth
category
is a document sharing tool
so document sharing tool like what what
are the examples they provide oh
um a common way to send digital
documents is attach them to an email
that option isn't always ideal
however because you can't always tell
when or if the recipient got them
like google drive sort of thing yeah you
can use red receipts but they only work
if the recipient hasn't blocked or
declined them
okay all right we'll put a link to that
in the show notes enjoy
those five different they say five apps
right but really it's just five
categories to help you go
paperless or maybe a better way to say
it is paper light
if we go paper light in which ryan and i
are even though during our podcast it's
by far the most
paper heavy part of our week in fact i
i can't think of any time i print
anything else except during
our podcast so i can avoid having any
screen in this room whatsoever
yeah and it is calming strangely right
but
by removing those screens i feel like
it's it's just me and you in this room
and
sean and jordan who are naked it's
really strange i don't know why they do
this
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively
on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast
and youtube channel 100 percent
advertisement free